PlayStation now is a great service that
lets you stream ps3 games on platforms
like ps4 but what if you want to play
those games somewhere else well PS now
is headed to pc it's coming to the UK
first then North America shortly after
if you already have a subscription it'll
work on PC to even better you don't
actually need any additional platforms
to play these games although a dualshock
4 controller is required speaking of
controllers a wireless USB adapter is
also being released by sony the $25
dongle will be compatible with both PC
and Mac though it's not clear if it adds
some specific functionality you can
already connect your Dualshock 4 through
bluetooth or USB cable in any case it's
good to know you have options since the
controller is required PlayStation now
offers individual ps3 game rentals but
you can also get a one month
subscription for twenty bucks or three
months for 45 the service doesn't have a
specific PC launch date at this time but
you can head over to gamespot for the
recommended specs and for all the
biggest PlayStation news you're already
in the right place